I wanted to sort of get back to you know
this that I've finally had in the first
film a bit and no make me a little more
kind of grounded and just humanize him a
bit you know it's very easy for these
characters become unrelatable and exist
off in the stratosphere and you know and
and this was about you know it's making
him more human you know and we see in
one of the first scenes in the in the
trailers we've seen that the scene where
they trying to pick up a hammer and
they're in casual gear it's like what
these guys do when they're not saving
the world and that was fun for me and
and anytime we got to do that and supply
Ramis was the best part do you guys see
both Captain America and Thor kind of
his kindred souls and how that dynamic
works between the two of them when you
guys are on screen together lovers can
do you read the president yeah well I
mean there's just forever we wear
necklaces with a little broken heart
it's Jerry Maguire tomorrow night so we
go I'll be Tom he's the Jerry to the mom
Maguire you guys have both had the
opportunity to play your characters with
other directors at the same time and
then come back and work with Joss what
was it like coming back and working with
Joss again nightmare it's it's it's it's
tricky for him because you know when you
go to your individual movie or should I
say when your on the Avengers films you
have all these people that we know very
well and it's it really is like you know
it's like a party and everyone's it's
hard to wrangle everybody and I think
josh has we heard shut up quite a few
tones a lot set from jealous guys hey
you just kind of we're in trouble like
you feel like you're 12 years old in
trouble with that school we have to work
this this The Avengers have have always
been a really incredible ensemble
Avengers age of Ultron takes it up
another level what was it like getting
back together with that whole group
again and with the addition of a few
other people as well I think we just
answered that
but again
you're gonna use a new reading how about
this how about what was it like
welcoming the new car the new cast yeah
we'll segue Avenue well we just say to
them you know it's a process yeah
exactly you think you know what there's
only enough room for so many superheroes
paid it now they're awesome those guys
it was cool because it you know you
gotta get to comfortable almost and you
know everyone's rhythms and then a few
people get thrown in the mix and it gets
disrupted in the best way and you know
that's why I think people love this this
film and even more so than the first one
off I've heard and I think because
there's new additions you know and they
were great you know being the new guy on
the playground it's got to be tough but
they it was seamless you know what I
mean by day three or four Lizzy just
fell you know Aaron was like it was it
was now every Marvel movie brings
something unique and different to its
audience what is it that you guys are
hoping the audience gets out of Avengers
age of Ultron I hate that question sorry
I don't know well it's hard to say
without giving away the movie yeah what
can I expect I mean I think in the first
time it was about them coming together
as a team and and and trying to work out
who's gonna lead and what have you and
they sort of let out me and then well
that's debatable steam and in this one
they're like you know what Thor's
clearly the strongest and that's how the
film plays out you know
you